bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 23 novembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour en votre actualité locale
accompagnés des journalistes de la
rédaction ainsi que de nous inviter tout
de suite les titres de cette édition
novembre mois de l'économie sociale et
solidaire un mois pour évoquer cette
activité qui cherchent à concilier
activité économique et l'utilité sociale
qui cherche également à faire prévaloir
les personnes sur la recherche de
profits aujourd'hui à la derrière une
table ronde se tenait pour expliquer les
dernières mesures dans ce domaine de
président de la république demande une
révision de la constitution de la vème
république pour agir face au terrorisme
pourquoi une telle décision et surtout
quels changements à attendre à l'analyse
de stéphane mans son professeur de droit
constitutionnel et doyen honoraire de la
faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines et enfin la
15e fête du conte organisée par les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines se déroulera jusqu'au 6
décembre
quinze jours de programmation est pas
moins de cinquante sept spectacles
proposés sur l'ensemble du territoire et
au 1er janvier 2016 la complémentaire
santé obligatoire rentrera en vigueur
pour toutes les structures employeuse à
cette occasion et dans le cadre du mois
de l'économie sociale et solidaire des
associations ont organisé cet après midi
une table ronde à la verrière les
différents acteurs de l'économie sociale
et solidaire étaient invités à se rendre
à la maison de quartier dans les parcs
pour y participer
un reportage de william el est jérémy
quesada président trésorier ses
représentants d'associations tous le
même objectif aujourd'hui comprendre ces
nouvelles obligations de protection
sociale des mesures auxquelles ils
seront soumis en tant qu'employeur
malgré leur statut d'association et qui
reste assez obscur pour certains
me parle pas du tout donc chez les
renseignements et je les trouve surtout
pour la mutuelle pour nous on est on se
sentait pas concernée en tant
qu'association et la dsn encore moins
parce que c'est un dans le monde
associatif c'est quelque chose dont on
n'avait jamais entendu parler et on n'a
aucun courrier officiel sur le fait que
ça se mette en place soit le 1er janvier
2016 soit le 1er janvier 2017
donc c'est vraiment une grande
découverte pour nous organiser paris
grain et vie associative 78 ces tables
rondes permettent aux différents acteurs
de l'économie sociale et solidaire
d'éclaircir certaines mesures la
première est la mise en place d'une
complémentaire santé obligatoire pour
tous les employeurs dès le 1er janvier
2016 déjà un président de l'association
c'est pas forcément besoin d'un
professionnel donc il n'a pas forcément
les mêmes appuis que le secteur économie
traditionnelle pour pouvoir
être compétent pour tous ces sujets là
qu'est ce qu'il faut prévoir comme
garantis quels sont les niveaux de
garanties nécessaires et c'est donc
simplement l'aspect technique de la loi
en terme d'obligation réglementaire de
garantie deuxième révolution la dsn
déclaration sociale nominative qui va
rassembler toutes les déclarations
faites par les employeurs aux
différentes caisses en une seule et même
déclaration qui prendra effet courant
en fait on se rend compte que les
structures de l'ess à ce qu'ils sont
employeuse 190 % des structures
associatives des associations et
beaucoup de ces associations sur
bénévoles mais pour se développer créer
de l'emploi et ses obligations de
complémentaire santé dsn trend court dès
qu'il y à un salarié au sein de la
structure est donc cet accompagnement
administratif est nécessaire et
indispensable
une après-midi pour s'informer et
comprendre ces nouvelles mesures mais
aussi un moyen de rencontres informelles
pour les différents acteurs de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et ce
soir en plateau nous accueillons
stéphane minson boussois et machines à
brax est un train mutation alors je le
rappelle vous êtes professeur de droit
constitutionnel à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
vous êtes venu nous expliquer plus
concrètement l'état d'urgence mais aussi
la révision de la constitution
alors après les attentats de paris donc
du 13 novembre dernier le président a
déclaré au congrès de versailles le 16
novembre qu'il souhaitait faire évoluer
les articles concernant les pleins
pouvoirs et l'état de siège est
également annoncé le prolongement de
l'état d'urgence pour trois mois
alors tout d'abord stéphane minson état
d'urgence votée à l'origine pour faire
face aux événements liés à la guerre
d'algérie donc en 1955 a été revotée là
c'est une mesure spéciale qui restreint
les libertés c'est une c'est un
dispositif dont vous le dit à juste
titre dont l'objet consiste en effet à
alors restreindre les libertés mais je
crois qu'il est plus juste de dire de
mettre en place une légalité de crise
c'est à dire une légalité adapté à la
force des événements
il ne s'agit pas de supprimer toute
garantie légale mais il s'agit
simplement d'adapter le droit pour une
période particulière et surtout pour une
période limitée
donc on avait justement là il y avait
beaucoup de perquisitions qui ont eu sur
toute la france
ça permet de faciliter notamment ces
perquisitions
absolument la philosophie du texte de
1955 et de la loi du 20 novembre 2015
qui a été votée récemment ça consiste
essentiellement à transférer à
l'autorité administrative c'est à dire
essentiellement au ministre de
l'intérieur et au préfet des pouvoirs
des compétences qui d'ordinaire serait
placé sous l'autorité du juge judiciaire
du parquet des juges d'instruction du
juge de la détention et des libertés etc
exemple type le préfet aux ministres
peuvent ordonner des perquisitions alors
qu'en temps normal la légalité exige que
ces perquisitions soient conduites
notamment et surtout par des juges
d'instruction donc par l'autorité
juridictionnelle donc c'est soul et une
légalité particulière qui va permettre
de donner des pouvoirs exceptionnels à
l'autorité administrative perquisition
vous l'avez dit restrictions de la
liberté d'aller et venir
on a vu qu'un préfet dans l'yonne avait
pu mettre en place un couvre-feu qui
interdit aux personnes de se déplacer de
22h à 6h du matin de telles mesures ne
seraient pas nécessairement illégale en
temps normal mais leur légalité se voit
confortée par la situation d'état
d'urgence
concrètement pour les citoyens qui ne
sont pas inquiétés par action qu'est ce
que ça change
alors pour les citoyens ça peut
justement changer les choses par exemple
en matière de liberté de réunion
vous l'avez constaté en ile de france
les manifestations publiques sont
interdites pour des questions de
sécurité
c'est pas le cas nécessairement partout
en province voilà ce qui peut changer ce
qui peut changer aussi c'est le
l'interdiction de circuler dans
certaines zones
à certaines heures pour encore une fois
des raisons liées à la sécurité à
l'ordre public pour faciliter également
le travail des enquêteurs
absolument le travail des enquêteurs là
c'est plus ou moins discutable mais on
voit par exemple que dans les
perquisitions qui sont conduites si
j'ose dire on ratisse très large c'est à
dire que tout n'est pas nécessairement
en lien direct avec les événements du 13
novembre
on a vu par exemple que ces
perquisitions avaient donné lieu à des
saisies de drogues de substances
illicites et ses cibles le travail des
enquêteurs est évidemment facilité de
manière très large donc cet état
d'urgence a été votée pour trois mois
est-ce que c'est reconductible justement
il va durer plus longtemps alors la loi
a donné au gouvernement et
l'administration un délai de trois mois
mais deux observations la première c'est
que le gouvernement n'est pas obligé
d'aller jusqu'au terme de ces trois mois
lorsque l'état d'urgence avait été
prorogé par la loi en 2005 à l'occasion
de la crise des banlieues le
gouvernement ne s'en était servi que
pour une période de deux mois donc il
s'était arrêté avant il peut toujours le
faire
deuxième observation si le gouvernement
souhaite projet de nouveau cette période
alors il doit re celui-ci telle
autorisation du législateur il va
vouloir que le législateur revote une
nouvelle loi pour prolonger encore alors
maintenant ce qui concerne la révision
de la constitution alors ces décisions
est impulsée par le gouvernement afin de
modifier certains articles et d'induire
un régime civil de crise qu'est ce qu'un
régime s'il de crise un régime civil de
crise c'est la commission balladur pour
la révision de la constitution
commission qui s'était qui avait rendu
un rapport en 2007 avant la révision de
2008 sur demande de
nicolas sarkozy alors président de la
république et ce régime de crise serait
si vous voulez une sorte de synthèse
entre l'état de siège qui est prévue à
l'article 36 de la constitution
aujourd'hui alors l'état de siège c'est
une forme de militarisation de
l'administration pour des situations
encore plus grave de se parer de
numérisation à la maison c'est quelque
chose qui fait un peu peur qu'il ay
frier des gens ça peut effrayer oui
enfin la modification dangereuse à une
station qui peut être là pour le coup
c'est une situation si vous voulez de
deux conflits armés
plus ou moins généralisée sur le
territoire une sorte de guerre civile si
vous voulez donc cette cet état de siège
est prévue à l'article 36 est l'objet si
on a bien compris de la volonté du
président de la république serait donc
de réviser la constitution pour inclure
à côté de cet état de siège à l'article
36 l'état d'urgence et l'ensemble est à
deux sièges plus état d'urgence
formeraient cette situation applicable
en cas de crise de christine et donc
l'état de siège ça qu'on fera peut-être
plus de pouvoir donc à l'armée alors
l'état de siège
il ya quand même et fort heureusement
des conditions pour qu'ils soient
déclenchées par le pouvoir exécutif et
ses conditions fort heureusement encore
une fois ne sont pas réunies dans les
circonstances actuelles il faudrait
vraiment des soulèvements armés par
exemple des processus au cours
desquelles les militaires sortirait des
casernes avec leurs armes pour renverser
le gouvernement
des menaces de de putsch on n'est pas
heureusement encore et j'espère qu'on y
viendra jamais dans cette situation donc
la situation correspond plutôt de
manière assez exacte d'ailleurs à l'état
d'urgence
quand on parle de réviser à la
constituent la constitution c'est
quelque chose qui fait peur aux français
vous comprenez cette peur il faut pas il
faut pas avoir peur d'une révision de la
constitution vous savez la constitution
de 1958
elle a été insuffisante vème république
donc a été révisée 24 fois déjà alors
simplement ce qu'il faut savoir c'est la
réviser dans quel sens et la réviser
pourquoi pour y inclure des garanties
supplémentaires pour y inclure des
compétences supplémentaires
il faut que les deux les deux espèces
équilibre parce que ces affaires de
situation de crise sont toujours axé sur
la même question de question
fondamentale pour l'état de droit c'est
d'une part le respect des libertés
publiques fondamentales et d'autre part
octroyé au gouvernement et
l'administration les moyens suffisants
pour pouvoir faire face à des menaces
très forte
alors justement un poids que cette
concision soit révisée il faut qu'ils
gagnent plusieurs conditions qui soient
réunies alors c'est le congrès le
congrès qui a entendu et écouté le
présent de la république la semaine
dernière c'est la tâche du congrès la
compétence du congrès que de se
prononcer sur une proposition un projet
de révision
la constitution exige que pour être
révisé il faut que au congrès soit réuni
une majorité des trois cinquièmes des
parlementaires trois cinquièmes des
parlementaires ça veut dire que la
majorité parlementaire à elle seule ne
peut pas voter et faire passer cette
révision il faut obligatoirement que la
majorité est donc le présent de la
république soit en accord avec son
opposition
est ce que justement c'est nécessaire
selon vous parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
français qui craignent un peu que l'on
se retrouve comme aux états unis avec le
patriot act
c'est nécessaire il faut à voter cette
quatrième agression cette j'allais dire
cette crainte elle n'est pas justifiée
du moins la simple révision de la
constitution ne nous entraînerait pas
vers la situation qu'ont connue les
états unis jusqu'à une période récente
puisque le patriot act l'une de ses
caractéristiques fondamentales c'est son
application dans le temps il s'est
appliqué pendant plusieurs années
le seul fait d'inscrire l'état d'urgence
dans la constitution n'implique pas
évidemment la mise en oeuvre de cette
situation exceptionnelle pour plusieurs
mois voire pour plusieurs années l'objet
simplement consiste à rendre la
procédure à rendre ce processus plus
solide plus robuste
en mettant à l'abri les loi d'état
d'urgence d'éventuels censure de la part
du conseil constitutionnel et en
prévoyant un surcroît de garanties
notamment l'avis préalable ça c'est ce
que les juristes demandé à mon avis ils
ont raison l'avis préalable du conseil
constitutionnel avant le déclenchement
de l'état d'urgence donc là réside la
conscience temps ça prendra
nécessairement un peu de temps parce
qu'il faut une forme de consensus pour
réviser la constitution ça ne peut pas
se faire dans dans l'urgence je voudrais
vous dire que même lorsqu on vote une
loi alors la loi du 20 novembre et le
contre exemple mais il fallait aller
vite mais on ne révise pas la
constitution en bâclant les débats
puisqu'il faut quand même réunir trois
cinquièmes des voix au congrès merci
beaucoup
stéphane minson pour toutes ces
explications et et enfin sachez que pour
informer les citoyens sur l'état
d'urgence mais aussi sur les manières
dont on peut collectivement faire
société une réunion une réunion par non
publique aura lieu le mardi 24 novembre
à 20h30 salle de la boissière attrape en
présence de benoît hamon candidat du
parti socialiste aux régionales et
député des yvelines
rachid benzine islamologue et alain
degois dit papy seront également à ses
côtés afin d'apporter leur éclairage sur
le contexte et nous revenons à la vie
locale à présent le marché dominical de
montigny le bretonneux situé place que
jacques coeur à l'assaut de riz s'est
agrandie ce dimanche pour la troisième
édition de good yvelines au total une
quarantaine d'exposants ont échangé
autour de la consommation responsable
des produits sains et locaux
un rendez vous immanquable pour ce
marché qui existe depuis maintenant une
vingtaine d'années les précisions avec
camille lambert
des veaux des ânes et des moutons au
coeur de montigny pour l'opération good
yvelines le marché artisanal et
biologiques de la souris s'est
transformée en ferme pédagogique pour le
plus grand plaisir des plus jeunes
viennent bien les animaux il y en a qui
met les bleus dont les enfants ont pu
nourrir les animaux tandis que les
parents chercher les bonnes affaires sur
les étals proposé par yvelines tourisme
du 14 au 22 novembre
good yvelines visait à faire découvrir
les produits locaux et le savoir faire
des artisans yvelines - il était
intéressant pour nous d associer donc à
une opération à l'échelle du département
ce qui nous permet d'avoir un
rayonnement plus important est une
initiative est intéressante surtout pour
mettre en avant tout ce qui est terroir
tout ce qui est filières courtes 40
stands ont été installés au lieu de 20
habituellement les commerçants étaient
invités à faire goûter leurs produits
expliqué leur démarche aux visiteurs une
initiative appréciée par marianne
laporte venu proposer ses 18 quiche fait
maison
tout est fait par mon mes propres soins
dans mon laboratoire qui se trouve chez
moi dans mon sous-sol et après je
revends sur le marché dans ma petite
carriole la troisième édition de good
yvelines s'est terminée dimanche avec la
clôture du marché à 15 heures plusieurs
événements de l'opération ont été
annulés en raison des attentats du 13
novembre
il faudra attendre encore quelques jours
pour savoir si ces attaques ont eu une
incidence sur la fréquentation par
rapport aux années précédentes
et comme chaque lundi nous retrouvons
assez fort and la manie pour à la
chronique culture bonsoir sephora alors
aujourd'hui nous allons parler vous
allez nous parler du salon histoire de
lire qui se tenait ce week end à
versailles exactement aux orphelins
alors quelques chiffres pour commencer
en 2014 28% seulement 28% des français
avait déclaré au ministère de la culture
avoir lu plus de cinq livres au cours de
l'année contre 39 en 2007
c'est vrai mais en même temps il ya
certains livres qui se vendent très bien
notamment des livres d'histoire je pense
donc à métronome de lorànt deutsch qui
est paru en 2009 et qui a été vraiment
un poisson un grand succès exactement je
sens l'historienne en vous c'était plus
de 2 millions d'exemplaires pour le
métronome de lorànt deutsch alors livres
d'histoire active le vent en poupe
nous sommes allés
vous posez la question oui je lis des
livres d'histoire parce que le présent
s'explique par l'histoire
ah non pas du tout un jour pourquoi j'ai
pas le temps oui ça me passionne nous ça
nous fait comprendre certaines choses et
puis quelques fois ça nous permet de
constater qu on fait toujours les mêmes
erreurs maintenant à travers certains
faits divers en face certes un certain
tournant historique j'ai envie de
retrouver ou des sources ou des
équivalences oui alors ce week-end avait
donc lieu la 8ème édition du salon
histoire de venir dans les très bons
de l'hôtel de ville et de
l'hôtel départemental de versailles
salon qui favorise la lecture par livres
d'histoire emmanuel de creepy adjointe
au maire de versailles est chargée de la
culture nous en parle
nous sommes très heureux de pouvoir
continuer ce cet événement qui est
vraiment très appréciée aussi du public
puisque l'entrée est libre
on peut y acheter des livres et ça
permet aussi de rencontrer des auteurs
de pouvoir assister à de nombreuses
conférences ça permet aussi de découvrir
des lieux magnifiques que sont par
exemple salon désagréable hôtel du
département est alors le succès était au
rendez vous écoutez oui pas loin de dix
mille visiteurs sont venus rencontrer
les 150 auteurs internationaux a tiré
par le haut lieu historique qu'est
versailles venus avec leur publication
alors parmi eux on pouvait voir
jean-louis blanco chantal delsol
benjamin stora au rendez-vous vraiment
un public d'initiés qui aime partager
anecdotes et savoure historique plus
particulièrement celui là parce que les
thématiques de compte c'est que les gens
aiment l'histoire
on est dans une ville d'histoire il ya
le temps aussi pour parler avec les gens
n'y a pas trop de mon simple luxe
généralice intéressé moment des
dédicaces qu'on parle avec eux sans
quand même il vous apprennent parfois
des choses on a des discussions quand
même qu'ils peuvent être
constructive qui se passe simplement le
bon jour en voir c'est pour qui
et en plus de l'espace habituel il ya
également cette année une nouveauté avec
des espaces bd oui alors vous aviez
l'espace habituel dans le salon de
l'hôtel de ville de versailles elle
l'espace jeunesse on pouvait retrouver
différents ouvrages sur les mystères de
l'antiquité où les plus grands monuments
de france est la grande nouveauté de
cette édition c'était l'espace bd dans
les salons de l'hôtel départemental
alors étaient présents notamment nicolas
tabary laurent vassilian pour iznogoud
de père en fils et pascal davoz osé jean
torton pour leur biographie de napoléon
bonaparte comme disait napoléon lui-même
t dessin vaut mieux qu'un grand discours
alors là on parle aux yeux on parle
alors rien on parlera dacquois
comme cinéma j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser précolombien après avoir lu
le temple du soleil verger il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont intéressés à
l'histoire pour avoir lu les addicks de
jacques martin alors en plus vous
pouviez profiter de 16 débat marque de
ce salon depuis l'origine 14 rencontres
une exposition autour de l'épopée
industrielle de la manufacture de saint
gobain une pièce de théâtre et
différentes lectures par des comédiens
en caution comme notamment dimanche avec
lorànt deutsch justement et c'est
vraiment cette richesse de programmation
qui fait la force de ce salon vrai
rendez vous aussi bien pour le public
que pour les professionnels un auteur
est toujours content de dédicaces et de
vendre ce sont son livre mais ici nous
faisons tout autre chose une foire
commerciale c'est d'abord un lieu un
lieu des changes
voilà où il ya des ya des cafés d'auteur
où on peut j'allais dire dialoguer poser
des questions avec un auteur touché un
auteur alors moi je viens en tant
qu'éditeur beaucoup d'auteurs seront
présents des rendez-vous comme cela il y
en a peu avec vraiment de beaucoup de
lecteurs beaucoup de fidèles des
conférences de qualité
et puis des salons qui voit là sont à la
fois identifié c'est à dire l'histoire
est l'unique rendez vous proposés je
pense que c'était la forte idée de sur
sa longue on en manque le
public pour tous généraliste m'a parfois
du coup pas de colonne vertébrale autant
de façons d'aborder le livre d'histoire
autrement et peut-être pourquoi pas de
retrouver le chemin de la bibliothèque
merci beaucoup et sephora on vous
retrouve mercredi à 18h30 pour kiosques
le magazine culturel et nous allons
continuer à parler de livres d'histoire
mais cela d'un jour un petit peu
différent
ce week end et marées la 15e fête du
conte de saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
nombreux conteurs prennent possession
des médiathèques et lieux partenaires de
l'agglomération jusqu'au 5 décembre
un ensemble de spectacles expositions et
ateliers de création sont proposés pour
vous faire découvrir l'univers des
contes traditionnels et contemporains
regardez ce reportage finissait fort
allemagne je suis inculte
parce que je mets en pratique août et un
sac parce que je me méfie de tout
heureusement que vos marieu urban et
auteur poète et fabuliste ouvrit la 15e
fête du conte de saint quentin en
yvelines samedi à parois yale des chants
des appâts raymond queneau toute
l'histoire de la fable été retracés
depuis l'antiquité
une écriture toujours contemporaine
avant les europe même le people au vième
siècle avant notre ère qu'il a utilisé
les animaux pour critiquer le puissant
je te laisse beaucoup notamment auprès
des jeunes générations
la fable qui parle maintenant de choses
de notre époque le compte de genre
narratif est fictif fait partie de la
famille de la littérature orale avec la
fable et l'épopée en raison de l'aspect
traditionnel et communautaire qui a
longtemps régit la création et la
circulation de ces histoires
le conte et la fable ont une vraie
portée didactique
c'est une façon
de d'approfondir la réflexion réfléchir
sur des choses simples mais qui sont
oubliés au travers de toute la
la profusion d'informations qui nous est
donnée aujourd'hui c'est bien qu'on ait
beaucoup d'informations mais il manque
le temps de réflexion aurait fable à
nous faire réfléchir
la fête du conte se prolonge jusqu'au 5
décembre dans les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et les lieux
partenaires une programmation déclinée
autour de spectacles expositions et
ateliers de création est à présent un
mot de sport le 7e tour de la coupe de
france de football s'est déroulée ce
week-end versailles qui évolue en dh
s'est incliné aux tirs au but à domicile
contre blanc-mesnil une équipe de leur
division des joueurs de la cité royale
ont pourtant largement dominé la
rencontre résumé du match avec emi klm
idron camille lambert pour les images
une défaite rageante versets qui évolue
en blanc ce samedi tomber contre le
blanc mesnil au 7e tour de la coupe de
france
dominateurs les versailles n'ont pas
réussi à trouver la faille malgré une
dizaine d'occasions
le score 0 0 ce manque de réalisme a
poussé les deux équipes à se départager
aux penaltys dans cette loterie les
joueurs de seine saint denis ont
remporté la mise 5 tirs au but à 4
pas su concrétiser toutes les occasions
qu'on a pu avoir au moins tu as de
franches en première mi-temps notamment
prenant le temps on aurait pu plier le
match assez rapidement on a réalisé le
masque ont souhaité dans la préparation
du match maintenant malheureusement en
termes de concrétisation des situations
nombreuses qu'on s'est procurées on a
été on a été faibles et malheureusement
un match on n'est pas notée sur un match
on est de noter sur le score donc là
donc on sort pénalties tant pis pour
nous on doit servir de ce match là pour
pouvoir rebondir et tirer les leçons de
ce de ce match avec une victoire
l'équipe de versets qui évolue en dh
aurait pu rencontrer mainvilliers une
équipe de dsr au 8e tour
un tirage au sort accessible qui laisse
des regrets au verset y est on est sorti
de la région parisienne on a fait un
premier tour national c'est intéressant
c'est bien mais on avait quand même
l'ambition d'aller plus loin
ce qui est intéressant c'est derrière
moi derrière il est quelque chose de
sympa à faire et malheureusement on a
raté cette marche
donc on peut 130 km heure après cette
aventure en coupe de france versailles
devra se reconcentrer dès ce dimanche
sur le championnat les joueurs de la
cité royale sont pour l'instant 2e du
classement avec cinq points de retard
sur le leader lille euro et avant de
refermer ce journal une dernière
information vous l'avez sans doute
ressenti les températures ont largement
chuté ces derniers jours la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a mis en place alors le plan
hivernal voirie accompagner cette année
encore de son service d'alertés sms
jusqu'au 31 mars 2016 alors en cas
d'alerté préfectoral pour fortes chutes
de neige ou épisode verglaçant la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous propose
d'être informé en temps réel par sms
pour bénéficier de ce service il suffit
de vous inscrire sur le site internet
www.ca quentin en yvelines au point fr
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivis tout de suite
rester avec nous vous avez rendez vous
avec emi calais et demi d'euros pour le
site sport je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée
à demain
il